7:00.
TUCKER CARLSON IS UP NEXT.
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
AS WASHINGTON FUSSES OVER THE
RUSSIA HOAX FOR A THIRD YEAR
IN A ROW, A LOT OF OTHER
THINGS ARE HAPPENING THAT
DON'T GET THE ATTENTION THEY
DESERVE.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE BIG TECH
COMPANIES LAUNCHED THE
FIERCIST ATTACK YET ON YOUR
RIGHT AS AN AMERICAN TO FOLLOW
YOUR CONSCIENCE, AND TO SAY
WHAT YOU BELIEVE.
UNLIKE THE EARLIER GENERATIONS
OF THE AUTHORITARIANS.
THE TECH MOGULS DON'T SAY IT
ALOUD.
THEY ARE NOT HONORABLE ENOUGH
TO STATE IT CLEARLY.
INSTEAD THEY DRONE IT IN THE
SOOTHING BANALITY.
LISTEN TO ZUCKERBERG SAYING
FREE SPEECH IS SOMETHING TO
GET BEHIND.
>> WE ARE TAKING A PROACTIVE
ROLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PARTNERS AND THE DEVELOPERS
USE THE SERVICES FOR GOOD.
WE ARE FOCUSED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RECOMMENDATIONS AND
THE DISCOVERY SERVICES AREN'T
HIGHLIGHTING THE GROUPS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE REPEATEDLY SHARING
MISINFORMATION OR THE HARMFUL
CONTENT.
WE WORK HARD TO COMPLETELY
REMOVE GROUPS IF THEY EXIST
PRIMARILY TO VIOLATE THE
POLICIES OR TO DO THINGS THAT
ARE DANGEROUS.
>> Tucker: WHO KNEW FASCISM
COULD BE SO CHIRPY.
GROUPS THAT DO THINGS THAT ARE
DANGEROUS.
DANGEROUS, WHAT DOES IT MEAN?
DANGEROUS HURTING OTHER THINGS
OR SAYING THINGS THAT
ZUCKERBERG DOESN'T LIKE OR
CONSIDERS BAD FOR BUSINESS?
YESTERDAY WE FOUND OUT
FACEBOOK RELEASED THE LATEST
ENEMIES LIST.
ALEX JONES, MILO YUNAPOLI, IS
LOUIS FARRAKHAN, LAURA LUMAR,
ALL DESIGNATED DANGEROUS
INDIVIDUALS AND BANNED FROM
FACEBOOK.
THE COMPANY INFOWARS BANNED AS
WELL AND DESCRIBED AS A
DANGEROUS ORGANIZATION.
DIDN'T SAY HOW.
HOW DANGEROUS IS INFOWARS?
FACEBOOK SAID YOU CAN BE
BANNED FOR SHARING CONTENT
UNLESS YOU SIMULTANEOUSLY
DENOUNCE IT.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
HE IS NOT JUST CENSORING
OPINIONS, HE IS DESCRIBING
WHICH POLITICAL OPINIONS YOU
ARE ALLOWED TO HAVE, WHICH
CONVERSATIONS ALL OF US IN THE
COUNTRY CAN HAVE ABOUT
AMERICA.
KEEP IN MIND THAT NOBODY VOTED
FOR MARK ZUCKERBERG.
HE IS 34 YEARS OLD.
HE IS COMPLETELY CUT OFF FROM
REALITY.
HE IS WORTH $72 BILLION.
YET, HE CAN SINGLE-HANDEDLY
MAKE THE FIRST AMENDMENT
IRRELEVANT AFTER 250 YEARS.
HERE IS THE MOST AMAZING THING
OF ALL.
THE MEDIA THINKS THAT IS
GREAT.
JOURNALISTS ARE SUPPOSED TO
DEFEND FREE SPEECH.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT IS THEIR
JOB SINCE THEY MAKE A LIVING
FROM IT.
WHEN CORPORATE AMERICA ISSUES
AN ORDER AND MARK ZUCKERBERG
SAYS JUMP, THE QUESTION IS HOW
HIGH, MR. ZUCKERBERG?
LISTEN TO THEM CELEBRATE MARK
ZUCKERBERG AND SELL YOU OUT
COMPLETELY.
>> WHY ARE THEY DOING THIS
NOW?
>> WELL, THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION TO WHY THEY WAITED
THIS LONG.
>> YES.
EXACTLY.
>> SO JONES HAS BEEN BANNED
FROM FACEBOOK FOR A LONG
PERIOD OF TIME.
BUT NOW THEY BANNED HIM AND
THEY BANNED HIS UNDERLING.
>> KICK HIM OFF THE PLATFORM.
GREAT FOR NOW BUT IT DOESN'T
ROLL BACK THE CLOCK.
>> YOU HAVE THE FIRST AND THE
SECOND AMENDMENT RIGHT NOW AND
I DON'T THINK THAT THE
FOREFATHERS SAID WELL, YOU CAN
SAY ALL SORT OF HATEFUL THINGS
AND SPREAD IT AROUND THE
WORLD, LITERALLY SPREAD IT
THROUGH THE INTERNET.
>> I HAVE NO ISSUE WITH IT AT
ALL.
I WANT THEM SHUT DOWN.
I WANT THEM SILENCED AND
MUTED.
THEY ARE HORRIBLE FOR THE
SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: I WANT THEM SHUT
DOWN.
I WANT THEM SILENCED.
I WANT THEM MUTED!
DON'T WORRY.
THESE PEOPLE AREN'T TERRIFYING
OR ANYTHING.
DON'T KID YOURSELF.
IT'S NOT JUST ALEX JONES THEY
WANTED SILENCED, MUTED, SHUT
DOWN!
RECENTLY THE POINTER INSTITUTE
A NON-PROFIT THAT IS SUPPOSED
TO SUPPORT JOURNALISM PUT OUT
A LIST OF WHAT THEY CALLED
UNRELIABLE NEWS OUTLETS.
HE CRAFTED THE LIST WITH THE
HELP OF THE SOUTHERN POVERTY
LAW CENTER.
YOU CAN IMAGINE WHO MADE THE
LIST.
WASHINGTON FREE BEACON, "DAILY
CALLER," "DAILY SIGNAL."
EVERYBODY WHO IS NOT MSNBC OR
PRECISELY ALIGNED WITH THE
POLITICS.
POINTER CALLED FOR THE
ADVERTISERS TO BLACKLIST AND
THEREFORE BANKRUPT THE NEWS
OUTLETS.
CRUSH THEM.
THE FELLOW PROGRESSIVES
APPLAUDED.
AS FAR AS THEY ARE CONCERN,
THIS IS TOTAL WAR.
WHAT WE ARE WATCHING IN REAL
TIME IS THE COUNTRY BECOME
UNFREE.
SO WHO IS DEFENDING US IN ALL
OF THIS?
US WHO MIGHT DISSENT FROM MARK
ZUCKERBERG'S VIEW OR THINK
MSNBC LEADERS DON'T TELL THE
WHOLE TRUTH THE WHOLE TIME OR
DON'T TRUST ZUCKERBERG TO
CONTROL WHAT WE THINK.
WHO IS STANDING UP FOR US?
WHERE THE LEADERS IN CONGRESS?
WHERE IS THE WHITE HOUSE?
NOWHERE.
IF BIG TECH ISN'T HASSLING
THEM PERSONALLY AND DIRECTLY
AND THEIR ACCOUNTS ARE OPEN,
THEY DON'T SEEM TO CARE.
THEY ARE FOOLS.
ANY OF THE PEOPLE GET
RE-ELECTED IN A COUNTRY WHERE
LEFT WING TECH COMPANIES
CONTROL THE TERMS OF THE
POLITICAL DEBATE?
CAN YOU REALLY WIN A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IF
GOOGLE OPPOSES YOU?
NO.
YOU CAN'T.
NOT A CHANCE.